Now a CNN exclusive.
The U.S.
observed Russian naval vessels
preparing for a possible test
of a new nuclear powered torpedo
in recent weeks.
A senior official with direct kn
tells me among the vessels that
in those preparations was the Be
It's a cruise missile
submarine modified for special o
including launching unmanned und
vehicles.
That includes the Poseidon torpe
as it's known, seen here.
It is a nuclear powered
unmanned underwater
vehicle capable of carrying
both conventional and nuclear mu
with a nuclear propulsion system
that gives it virtually limitles
In the last week, those Russian
observed leaving the tested test
in the Arctic Sea, heading back
without carrying out a test.
The U.S.
believes the Russians may have e
technical difficulties.
Joining me now to discuss this
and other Russia Ukraine news, r
Major General Mark Hertling, for
commanding general of the U.S.
Army, Europe and the Seventh Arm
general. Good to have you on.
Good to be with you, Jim.
Interesting items
we're talking about this morning
No question, this nuclear torped
or really underwater
unmanned vehicle here, it's
something that Putin himself
touted in his State of the Union
address in 2018.
How significant a weapon is this
and how significant in your view
they wanted it seems to carry ou
here but weren't able to.
Yeah well it's it's we're callin
the Poseidon
the Russians call it a Naito cal
the status six.
As you've been showing pictures
it's about four feet in diameter
about 14 feet long
but interestingly enough
it has the capability
to go literally a couple of thou
first at a slower pace
than at a larger pace or faster
I'm sorry.
It is designed to loiter off of
cities and carry a thermonuclear
Now, what I think we're hearing
the intelligence community is se
being loaded up on that Belgorod
class submarine
it tells me that it was part
of the nuclear exercise that Rus
so transparently advertised
over the last couple
of weeks, coming back in the por
They may just be transporting it
to see what it was like.
Part of an exercise
right now, I
don't think I
would put anything more into it
It's not like Russia, in my view
is preparing for a nuclear strik
Understood.
And that's to be clear here, a t
very different from a nuclear st
And we want to be clear about th
Let's talk about it, by the way,
without a nuclear detonation dev
attached to it.
Let's talk about the battlefield
now in Ukraine.
Russian forces significantly wit
from Hassan, the only provincial
that they were able to capture
in this ongoing invasion here.
How significant a loss is that f
And victory for the Ukrainians?
It's pretty big.
And we've been talking about thi
for weeks
as the Ukrainian forces have bee
attempting to surround those for
that are on the western
bank of the Pearl River.
That is where the Russian forces
decided, interestingly enough,
to take up defensive positions
with a large river
and a wide river at their back.
They have attempted now
to get across that river onto th
side of her southern province
and is
setting up multiple layers
of defensive positions across th
which you've got to understand i
will certainly allow the Ukraini
to liberate some of those cities
on the western bank of the Dnipr
But at the same time,
it would be very difficult right
for the Ukrainian forces to cond
what would be the equivalent of
to get across that river.
At the same time,
there is fighting going on elsew
and all of it seems to be in the
of the Ukraine forces.
We have heard some public discus
now of the potential for talks
to end this war.
Responding to those talks,
you hear Ukrainian officials onc
saying the condition for settlem
is that Russia leaves all occupi
territories they're not willing
land, in effect, for peace here.
Do you see a change in the attit
towards negotiations,
particularly from Western partne
In the U.S.?
And do you see any sort of unsta
pressure here on Ukraine to
think about talking?
I do not, Jim.
And I've been
reading the reports in a lot of
in magazines and newspapers as w
And I think these are a lot of p
saying, hey, there's an opportun
As winter is coming up,
the Russian forces have been bea
in several battlefield fronts.
It's time for Ukraine
to take a look at that.
I think the Biden administration
perfectly clear from the very be
that they will take Ukraine's
lead in terms of negotiation.
Now, Mr.
Zelensky has made it very clear
he wants to regain the sovereign
of his territory.
Interestingly, including Crimea,
something that will certainly pu
Putin in the defensive position.
But I've got to tell you,
Russia has not been very good
in terms of any of the operation
they have conducted.
They have continued to fail in e
attempting to regenerate
and move their forces around.
So there could be a potential op
for negotiation.
But again, I believe the United
is going to stand firmly behind
President Zelensky in what
he and the Ukrainian people want
There have been some concern
among Democrats and frankly, Rep
that I've spoken with it that a
win in this election here in the
would if not put an end to make
far more difficult to get new mo
new weapons systems to the Ukrai
at least get the votes to do so
to spend that kind of money.
It does appear still
the Republicans will take the Ho
Do you think that this puts in j
future financial and military as
for Ukraine from the US?
It's certainly going to put a di
we may we may have lost.
Sorry. Finish your thought, Mark
You disappeared for a moment.
Just quickly.
Yeah, sorry.
We have seen that politics
always play a part in funding co
funding operations
with a new political body.
There may be additional discussi
about that.
And truthfully, Jim, as we all k
all of the Western forces
have dedicated a lot of equipmen
personnel,
training personnel,
as well as ammunition to this fi
So I'm sure that a new group
of politicians
believing they're in
charge will have more debates ab
But we have been pretty clear
about saying we need to defend t
from a values based perspective
and the sovereignty of another c